the world of the medium begs to be
closely examined to be parsed for those
small details that begin to paint
monsters as something all too familiar
there's something disturbing about the
reminder of the evils that humans can
inflict on one another and how horrific
acts of abuse rarely if
ever result in a singular trauma the
after effects of such actions can fester
in the heart and mind of victims long
after and it's here that the medium
finds the basis for its story
one that concludes as a memorable
experience
in the medium you play as marianne a
powerful clairvoyant who travels to the
neva resort she goes there in search of
thomas a man who leaves her a strange
message telling her to find and help him
promising that he'll give her the answer
she seeks about her
past in return marianne is able to
commune with spirits and help them pass
on to the afterlife to that end the
medium plays out on two planes of
existence
the normal world and the spirit world
these two depictions of the world are
not black and white opposites instead
the game posits that they exist as
mirrors of one another
one manifesting literally with the other
only hints at figuratively
and via this shared window into both
perspectives the medium is able to
explore the trauma of its characters
through puzzle solving and riddles as
you explore the neva resort you'll
stumble into areas where the emotional
remnants of the world are so powerful
myrian is forced to traverse the space
in both the real
and spiritual plane at this point your
perspective is split forcing you to look
at and explore both worlds at once
navigating these spaces isn't
straightforward though obstacles in one
reality can halt your progress
in both these moments of dual reality
transform areas into self-contained
puzzle boxes where an understanding of
the space is necessary to move forward
as you continue the puzzles become more
elaborate
encouraging you to take an even closer
look at the environment in search of
clues the puzzles revolving around the
dual reality of marion's life for the
best part of the game
impressive in their technical
achievement as they are two separate
experiences
running side by side but beyond how cool
it is to see xbox's new hardware finally
get an
exclusive that accomplishes something
that feels very next-gen
these moments of dual reality also add
to the medium's gameplay myrian is able
to have an out-of-body experience
allowing you to control
only her spirit form for a limited time
god i hate this
so in order to solve certain puzzles you
may need marianne to be in two places at
once
regardless of whether they're a part of
the dual reality sections the puzzles
are satisfying to solve
most puzzles require a level of spatial
awareness or deductive reasoning they're
less about leaving you stumped and
geared more towards smartly navigating
spaces
as well you can't guess your way to
success figuring out what to do
shouldn't trip you up for very long
there's a great deal of incentive in
solving each puzzle prior to
arrival the naval resort suffered a
horrifying incident in which almost
everyone on the premises died
but no one knows why journeying deeper
into the resort begins to fill in those
gaps unveiling a mystery that compels
you to push further through the horror
in hopes of finding the answers you seek
the medium has stealth encounters and
chase sequences as well
both of these stem from encounters with
the maw the main antagonists of the game
the mod is an unsettling foe made all
the more so because you go a great deal
of the game not knowing
why it wants to be inside you but
knowing that it can appear at almost
any time thankfully there are a few
systems designed to ensure you don't
always outright fail if you make a
mistake during a chase or stealth
section
when captured provided you have spirit
energy you can emit a blast that
temporarily stuns the moth
allowing you to keep running or flee to
a hiding spot miriam can't hold an
endless supply of spirit energy but you
usually always have enough to escape at
least once
so the first time you're caught it's not
necessarily a game over
of course that doesn't dispel the
unnerving atmosphere when the maw is
nearby
stay with me
that feeling of unease is only
heightened by how you're able to
perceive the medium's world
bloomer team strips you of any agency
over the camera opting for a more
cinematic experience where at the mercy
of predetermined angles for every room
often you're forced to view a room from
a less than ideal perspective to the
game's credit
it's very effective for establishing the
tone of every moment allowing bluebird
team to orchestrate the same type of
shot composition seen in
well-choreographed films
or cinematic horror games like silent
hill the medium does a terrific job of
storytelling without explicitly telling
you what's going on so it's
disappointing when it goes out of its
way to explicitly lay things out
almost the entire game is a flashback of
past events as marianne recaps her
journey through the neva resort
narrating her innermost thoughts
feelings and convictions during each
moment
she's excessively vocal often explaining
revelations that do not need explaining
because the game has already
sufficiently established a situation
i had never felt anything so
desperate
it was calling out to me wanted to show
me something
yeah kelly burke's stellar performance
does much of the work in conveying
marianne's mental and emotional state so
getting narration about how she's
feeling just after inferring it from the
tone in her voice feels
redundant the medium gives you
everything you need to piece together
its puzzles and narrative but whereas it
leaves you to solve the puzzles on your
own
it goes too far in trying to ensure you
never miss a beat of its story
the medium's initial hook of finding
thomas in order to learn about marion's
origins isn't all that interesting but
as mentioned before the walls of neva
resort hide many compelling secrets
early on you discover evidence of
several seemingly unimportant but
fascinating stories that speak to what
transpired in the days
leading up to the massacre the left neva
resort abandoned many of these stories
tie into the puzzles more often than not
deducing the identity of someone and
understanding who they were is key to
moving forward thus to understand the
puzzle in front of you
you need to empathize with those who
once lived there to figure out how they
ticked even if you can't fully
comprehend the scope of their trauma
it's important to acknowledge it and try
to understand how it may have shaped
them
two moments in particular stand out once
we are entering the minds of victims
that went on to become victimizers
themselves
these sections play out in unique
dreamscapes inspired by the twisted
subconscious mind of the individuals in
question
they're both harrowing and intense
you're cutting away at the defenses that
someone has erected against the most
traumatic moments of their life
but they're important because they
clarify the thematic core of the
medium's message about only judging
someone after knowing both sides of the
story
in both cases marianne outright rejects
the use of an abusive upbringing to
forgive evil actions
you can feel bad for a villain for what
happened to them but that doesn't mean
you should ever forgive what they did
it's an important distinction and one
i'm glad the game makes and i think
therein lies why the medium works as
well as it does it's a horror game no
doubt about that but it also feels like
a game about the aftermath of horror and
how living with unresolved trauma can
create nightmares as damaging as the
initial event as scary as it is to be
chased by a monster it's far more
terrifying to see how one traumatizing
act
can have such a ripple effect on the
victim than those around them eventually
the medium's narrative threads begin to
weave together and the promise that
everything somehow connects in some
unforeseen way is a thrilling reason to
see the game all the way through
the references to real world events of
polish history make many of the
revelations hit that much harder
even if the supernatural aspects are
fictional it's deeply unsettling to
think about how some of the evil present
in this game
did actually occur and to that end the
medium's conclusion sticks with you it's
one last horrifying reminder that trauma
may not define a person but it can have
consequences we can't even begin to
foresee if it's not adequately dealt
with
i can't say i enjoyed the ending to the
medium but i am deeply satisfied with
how it sets up the inescapable nature of
its horrifying conclusion
you